サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッソウパサンパダ
サチットパリヨダパナン エータンブッダナサーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
今日は月例講演会でございまして
発表されているテーマに沿っていくつかのアイデアを考えてみたいと思います
今日のテーマは苦しみを乗り越えるブッダの道ということですが
まああんまりこのタイトルに沿ってないかもしれませんだけど
私はこの逆境という言葉に引っかかってしまったんですね
しかし この逆境ということについては
それは大変 大事に大事な現象であるということは
この子供たちに一回教えたんですから
あの それはちょっとした
パンフレットもなっていてね
もしかするといろいろ学校で配られているとは思いますが
まあそれは皆様にあまり関係ないというわけに
一回言いましたから そのテーマでは今日喋りませんね
いわゆるポイントは 逆境を乗り越えようとするところで人は成長するんだということでね
だから悪い状況に遭遇したら逃げるなよという
子供たちに必要なポイントでありました
今日はもうちょっと大人向けのことをお喋りしたいと思います
はい まあ私はちょっと引っかかってしまったんだから
この逆境という言葉に
ですから いきなり逆境ということはね
まあ大雑把で考えるんじゃなくてね
まあ仏教的に何でもきめ細かく分けて分けてみるんですね
いわゆる分解してみるんですね
そうすると物事はわかるんですね
いくつかのステージに分けましたけどね
ステージ 1 というのは
生きられない状態 これ一番危険な状態なんですね
空気 水などが汚れて使えない
これは大変危険な状態です
あるいは食べられるものはない
あるいはよくあることで
環境から攻撃を受けている
今 例で言えば この COVID 19 はある程度でこの範囲に入ります
しかし このステージ 1 という風に言えるところまでは進んでいないんです
昔はね まあ環境のせいで
ものすごい 酷いことになったんだから
まあ言えば この昔ね イタリアで起きた火山
何でしたかね  ポンペイ火山
ポンペイ火山とかね で
全部街はなくなってしまったんですね
人々はそのまま亡くなっちゃって
今発掘されてみんな見ることができますけどね
その場合は これ 環境の攻撃だからね
お手上げですね で 将来的に水と空気が汚れる予定ですからね
だからあまり将来明るいという風にはならないんですね
大体計算していますからね
飲み水がすごく 少なくなっていくんだよとね
それで大会社たちがね
国の世界にある水の資源をね
独り占めにしようとしているところなんですね
スリランカの資源もなんか取られているみたいですね
かなり前から契約して
だから水がなくなっちゃうと
またそちら儲かりますね
そういうことで このステージ 1 というのは
まああまり今私たちにはないんですね
これこのままだったら死に死ぬしかないやという状況はないんですね
そういうことで 次のセクションに入ります
ステージツー 二ですね
これはあんまり一般的には考えられなく
人間の性格 危険ですよ
ステージ1とまあほぼ同じく危険なんですね
互いに憎しみ合ったり
相手を疑ったり 敵視したりする状態
こういうものは時々地球地球スケールで起こる時がありますよ
ある一箇所で ある地方で互いに憎しみ合うということはあるんだけど
これはまあ 地球スケールになる可能性はありますね
怒り 恨みなどに心が支配されると
戦争状態が起きます それで戦争が起こるんですね
仏教では神話物語にしているんだけど
この将来はもうみんな世界的な戦争を起こして破滅になりますよと
人類がね というアイデアが当時ではそんなに考えられませんだから人々に
だからまあ神話神話っぽい物語に組み立てた方がアイデアが残るんです
我々は神話的なところを捨てちゃえ
捨てちゃえば  だからその将来的に人間の貪瞋痴があんまりにもひどくなって
奪い合いになっちゃって
だから残るはもう怒り
嫉妬 憎しみだけになるんだと
だから 人間見ても獣に見えるんだそう
自分以外の生命は だからパーリ語でエッサミゴーエッサミゴーと書いてます
これはミゴーっていうのは獣っていう意味でね
お前獣だよと だから たまに稀に我々は人間に対して
あの人は人間じゃない獣だよというケースあるでしょうに
じゃあその状態が世界的になったらどうなるのかと
なりますよ だからお釈迦様そうおっしゃってるんだから
なぜならば 人間の心の流れを全部お釈迦様は知ってるし
誰も貪瞋痴控えようとしないでしょうに
すべて貪瞋痴に燃料をあげる活動だけしているんだから
だから戦争状態が起こるんですね
今安全ですが 人の心そのものが信頼できないんですね
だから私は上や人間 互いに信頼しないということを書いたんだけど
やっぱり信頼できないのは人間は心なんで
やっぱり信頼できないんですよ
どうなるのかわからないんですね
心は もし世界スケールで戦争が起きたら
それが人類の破滅になります
世界戦争はね  2回も起きたんだけど
まあそれってのは世界戦争というだけで
世界的に広がったわけじゃないんですね
で まあ無理やり関係ない国々も引っ張ったんだけどね
まあ例えば自分の国もセカンドワールドの場合はね
第二次世界戦争の時はね
イギリス属民地でしたからね
で 自分たちの戦争に引っ張ってやろうではないかとかね
思ったんだけど 国民はもう中立的でいたんですね
関係ないやと だからそこイギリス支配者国にはなかなか難しかったんですね
軍人 強制的にね 軍隊に入れちゃったんだけど
入れた場合はそちらが
まあよくそういう人々から昔
子供の頃お話を聞いたんだけどね
私たちはもう政府指令だから入隊しましたけど
いきなり今我々は仏教徒だよと
ですから殺生しませんと
意味がないんだと あんた方は撃てと言っても撃ちませんよと
で 代わりに私たちを撃つならばどうぞ
だからそうすると 軍人にも意味がないでしょうね
それで考えたのは あの戦闘ではなくて
この裏方に回そうと いわゆる戦争っていうのはいっぱい仕事いろいろありますからね
ですから この料理作るやら物を運ぶことやらね
そういう鉄砲を持つ必要ない仕事にみんな回されたんですね
まあだからこの第二次世界戦争とは言うんだけど
世界は自分たちでやると思っているだけでね
中国は参加しなかったでしょうね
それにはわからない 参加しなかった国がいっぱいありましたからね
中国は占領されただけなんですね
中国は出てきて戦争してやるぞというふうにはなかったんですね
しかし 中国のね まああれでしたっけ
なんかどこかの香港などなど
イギリスのものでしたからね
そこを使っていたんですね
はい まあそれとはというより
すごい恐ろしい戦争が起こることはあり得る
それで人類の 存続はそこで終了するんですね
で 一人残らず死ぬことはありませんね
そういう戦争を受けてもね
原子爆弾がパチパチあちらこちらやっちゃうと
全ての人間 一人残らず死ぬということはなく
こういう戦いに行かないで隠れている一部の人々が残るんですね
ほんのほんのわずかな人々はね
そういう人々は全部文化すべて破壊しちゃうんだから
また自然と一緒に生活することになりましてね
やっぱり放射能がばらまいたらどうかなと
わからないんだけどね
また原始時代から文明を発達していかなくちゃいけなくなるんですね
そこで この人類破滅する原因は
我々は今も持っているんですね
互いに殺し合いをしている
これところがと書いてますけど
まあ心が ところが場所をね
今もあるようで それは別な意味でね
まあアフリカとかいろんなイスラム国々とかね
ものすごく人が殺し合い殺し合いやってるところありますね
だからみんな難民で逃げちゃうとかね
だからそこは地球スケールになっちゃうとどうなるのかと
同じ人間 同じ民族が自分たちで殺し合うということになるんです
あの武工ハランというね
なんかどこかの国の活動あるでしょうね
まあ西洋的なものは全てもうハランやと
ハランというのは禁止という意味でね
まあイスラム教によっては絶対あってはならないということでね
だから子供たち ちっちゃな子供たち
学校に行っちゃうと みんな捕まって連れて行って殺しちゃう
だからこの人間にはそういうこともあるということはわかるでしょうね
はい それで逆境のステージスリー
経済 なんで経済は逆境ですかね
笑 人の生きるための営みですね
経済っていうのは誰でもやっている
経済は人類のネットワークです
だからみんな まあこれを理解してほしい
経済っていうのはネットワークで
単独で成り立つものじゃないんです
一箇所が揺れると全体的に響きます
経済はそういうことです
例えば日本の経済は安全
安全だと 今は言ってませんだけど
そう言っていた時期もありましたからね
でもどこかでちょっとアメリカで何か起こると
がたっと倒れてしまうということはありましたしね
だから 例えば日本の中ででも
一つの会社が倒産したら
まああの会社は倒産したって当たり前っていうことじゃないんです
他の会社の会社にも関連ある会社に一番先に
それから二次的に三次的に関連ある人々も倒れてしまいますよ
今はこの世界的に経済状況がね
コロナの攻撃でね 揺らいでいますが
だからそういうことも起きちゃって
このこのネットワークが壊れるんですね
だからコロナはもう生理学的な生物学的なことだから
まあこれはなんとか まあ乗り越えることはできるとしたっても
それに関連して壊れる経済状況はね
大変なんですよ また復活させるのは大変です
経済は環境に依存しているので
今こそ利益を上げている経済組織もあります
例えば まあコロナの問題で大変だ
赤字だ もう倒産だと泣いていても笑っている人々もいますよ
ボロ儲けしている人もいます
だから これどう理解するのか
だからそれも環境依存なんですね
コロナですごい怖いほど金儲かった組織は
コロナが消えるとそこ倒産するんです
今 コロナがない状態で成長していた経済活動は今もう倒れた
倒れていくんですね だから経済っていうのは環境依存ということは理解しなくちゃいけないんですね
経済が成り立つ環境を理解しているならば
逆境に遭遇しないで済みます
これはかなり危険な状態ですけど
まあまあ 死ぬ運命にもなりますけど
時々ね 国々もものすごく飢えている状態にもなりますよ
だから冗談でもないんです
例えば日本の経済 いきなり壊れてしまったら
日本人がどう生活するのかっていうことはね
大変なことになるんです
ナチュラルは我々 我々はちょっと不自然な生き方をしているんですね
みんなどこかで畑を耕して
なんとかして生活しているならば
そんなに大きい問題にはなりませんね
今スーパーで買ってるんだからね
だからそれって自然の生き方ではないんですね
だから結構いつでも我々は危険な状態の中でいるんです
スーパーに品物を入れるところは個人事業じゃないんですね
もう大きな会社みたいな感じで
キャベツ作ったり ジャガイモ作ったり
大量にそれを集まって集めてスーパーに出しちゃいますから
そこも個人ということは消えているんですね
だからそれは経済システムになっているんですね
で これが危険です 結局は
このまま環境を続ければいいんだけど
環境が壊れるとどうするのかと
しかし まあそこは人間の脳みそで考えて
なんとかなんとかできる可能性はあります
まあでも結構それ逆境はあることがあることあることはあります
はい 次 はい まあまだいろいろ考えがあったんだけど
そこで一旦やめて 仏教の見方を説明しようかなと
生きることが苦なので
順調は成り立たない 仏教はいきなりもう大胆に喋るんです
みんな順調に生きていたいでしょ
仏教はこれはありえないんだと
順調なんかないやと という立場なんですね
だから仏教的に言えば
それに逆境なんですよ
逆境がなく順調になったっていうことは
もうない ジャータカ物語はいろいろな仏教のエピソードの中でも
このある時間だけ ほんのわずかな時間
順調でいたっていうストーリーはあるんです
しかし そんなに素晴らしい社会システムができて
みんな豊かになったならば
そのまま続ければいいんじゃないかと思うんだけど
続けられないんですね
これの場合は 明らかに仏教のということの政治なんですね
政治がしっかり正しく道徳を重んじてやるならば
その国が豊かになるんだと
だから 国民には自由と
安心を与えなくちゃいかんですね
仏教はいつでも国民には自由に自分を考えること
自分用に生活できる平和な環境を作ってあげなくちゃいけないんです
政府は昔ストーリーで出てくるのは王様ですね
当時王様しかいなかったんだからね
王政でしたからね だからこの王っていうのは政府なんですね
現代的に入れ替えると
政府はあれをやってはあかん
これをやってはあかん
この商売はあかんとか
あれこれと言うとね それで人の自由がなくなるんですね
だから道徳を重んじなく
すごい大切にするんじゃなくちゃいけないんですね
これは政府の仕事なんですね
道徳っていうのは 現代的に言えば法律になってますけど
法律はあんまり道徳というふうには見えないんですね
まあ俺で禁止していることは道徳的にもダメなものなんですが
法律はしっかり道徳 国民に道徳を守るために作りましょうという気持ちで作ったものじゃないんですね
どうやって国民に罰金払う払わせるのか
どうやって逮捕されるのか
それだけいわゆる人をいじめることが目的なんです
だから法律のこの人の権利を守るっていうことがメインテーマになってないんですね
人の権利 生きる権利 みんな守るべきである
守らない場合は まあこういうこういう罰金
パニッシュメント 罰になりますよというふうにね
ですから このじゃあ順調であった時期
仏教的に言えばね その場合は王様がものすごい道徳的な人間で
智慧がある人で 国民は我が子のように慈しむ人で
我が子には権利あげるでしょうに
そうなってくると 国民はまあ王様の王様がすごい道徳を重んじる人だから
自分たちが隠れて悪いことをしようという気持ちが基本的に国スケールでなくなっちゃうんですね
だから敵がないんだから
何かそれでみんな何かいろいろ面白いことを考えると
私はこういうことをします
私はこういうことをしますとか
それに環境を整えてあげるんですね
政府が 大体ある人がすごい農業に興味あって
もう植物をね 作物を育てたく育てたいと
それで勉強もしていて
やってもその人にできないでしょうね
それで だから必要なサポートをする
土地を分けてあげたり
最初に必要なものは全部提供してあげて
じゃあ頑張ってくださいと
その人はものすごく万々歳
気持ちいいんですね 私はキャベツをたくさん作りたかったんだけど
政府からこの土地を分けてもらいましたと
それだけじゃなくて もう種も手に入るように
肥料も手に入るようにしてくれたと
じゃあやろうではないか
だから監督いらないんです
本人がやりたがったことだから
そのように商売をやっている人やら
いろんなものを作る人やら
もう芸術的な人々やらね
いっぱいいろんなことをやりたがるんで
人間っていうのはみんな同じことをやりたがらないんです
それ 自分がやりたいことに
じゃあどうぞやってくださいというサポートが
国がやらなくちゃいかんですね
だから国のサポートがあって
国民にはものすごい自由があって
誰も指令していない 例えば今はみんなサラリーマンでしょう
自由じゃないね 結局は
奴隷システムなんですね
そう言うと怒る 怒るかもしれませんだけど
昔だったら奴隷システムがちょっと色が変わっただけで
奴隷だったらもう逃げられませんしね
今は会社嫌だったら辞めることはできる
それでそんな差があるんですね
奴隷には奴隷 食べるものだけあげればいいやと昔決めたんだけど
今はそうではなくて まあ生活基準
水準がありますから それに合わせて給料を払わなくちゃいけないという決まりがあるだけ
ですから この 雇われてどこかの偉い人のところで雇ってほしいと思う人には
ブッダが教えただったら
それはそれなりの人々がいるんです
人手が必要だという人々が
それに来る人々はやりたくて行くんだから
そこで会社システム 奴隷システムはできてないんですね
ある人 人々がいて どうしようか
私は将来は？とかね 誰かに雇ってもらえば楽ちんじゃとかね
自分がそう思っているんだから
もう人手が足りて足りてないところに行って
いかがでしょうかと 私を雇ってくれませんかと
どうぞどうぞということになるんです
そうすると またお互いにすごい友情関係が成り立つんですね
だから エンプロイヤーエンプロイ使用人と
雇用 雇用者と被雇用  雇用者と被雇用者
被雇用者 その関係はね
まあ昔もあったんですね
しかし お釈迦様もそちらにこの人権とかね
人の自由という言葉も取り入れて話すんですね
だからお釈迦様がおっしゃっているように
実際あったかどうかよくわかりませんけど
私はね お釈迦様は将来に向けて人々に語った可能性もあります
そこで なんでそんないいシステムができても壊れるのかというと
それは政治なんです 例えば王様の例で言えば
王様がよかったと 息子が同じくなるって保証がないでしょう
民主主義の場合も同じです
この総理大臣とこの政権はすごくやってくれたと
選挙で次に出てくる人々を同じくやるという保証はないでしょう
大体違うことをやっちゃいますね
だからアメリカの例でいえば
トランプさんが自分こそもう歴史的な素晴らしい大統領だと思ってね
アメリカ国民がものすごく自分のことを喜んで期待して拝んでいると思ったんだけど
人気のリストではオバマさんが上でね
残念ながらいまだに それで暴力まで
アメリカであまりあってはならんことをね
やらせたりしてね だから自分が自分のやっぱり政治システムあったんですね
自分のわがままで世界をこうやって支配するとというね
しかし バイデンさんが来たら同じことを全くやらないね
全く反対のことをやるんです
バイデンさんがお年ですからね
2回目出るかどうかもわからないし
次またコングレスパーティーがね
政権取ったらどうなるかわからんね
だからそこでまた不安現象があり得るでしょうね
ですから この順調っていうのは
わずかなピリオドで時間で成り立つかもしれませんが
ずっと続くということはないんです
だからゴールデンイーラと言いますね
英語でね 黄金の黄金時代
黄金時代ありますよ ほんのわずかショートピリオドなんです
はい それで仏教的に見れば
まあ人間は の生き方というのは生かしてくれることはない
この世の中で それを理解して
誰も自分を生かしてくれないんです
環境も他の生命も 優しく自分を生か生かしてくれることはありません
だからそれも逆でしょ
逆境でしょ 自分の命は自分の力で守らなくちゃいけないんです
大変でしょうね 環境が自分を潰そうとする
他の生命も自分を潰そうとしている
自分一人で自分を守らなくちゃいけないんです
だからすごい逆境がいつだって個人個人にあるんです
環境は常に逆境なので
環境と仲良くする能力を育てなくてはならない
環境は人間のためにあるものじゃないんです
地球は人間のために神様が作ったものじゃないんです
ですから 人間だけ亡くなったら
もう 100年経つと人間が作ったもの全部なくなりますからね
ニューヨークも森になりますからね
100年経つ必要もないんだそうです
まあピラミッドぐらいは残るでしょうと
ですから 我々の歴史は
我々は環境と対立してきたんですね
家を作る場合は 昔はもうやっぱり木を伐採して家を作るんですね
それから まあそれからレンガの家を作ることになったでしょ
焼いたレンガっていうのは自然破壊なんです
みんな考えてないんだけど
あれは何千年経っても自然に戻らないんです
日本の瓦とかは だからそれ自然破壊ですよ
自然破壊といっても 人はそうして生きているんです
例えばレンガの代わりに土で泥でちょっと固めてブリックスレンガを作ることはできますよ
焼かないで そうするとまあ 5年ぐらいになってくると
自然でそれはどんどんどんどん土に戻るんだから
家に住んでいる人々は大変なんです
また新しい家を作らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
それで考えたら これはもうレンガにしてやろう
コンクリートにしてやろうとかね
しかし もし私たちには自然となんか仲良く生きる方法があれば
それで逆境ってことはなんとなく緩和してしまうんですね
それは人間やってないね
それで生きることはもう大変ということ
例えば教育ありますね
教育がなかったら現代人は生きていられないんですね
乞食になるしかないんです
だから我々は大変です
生まれたら教育を受けなくちゃいけない
環境をよく学ばなくちゃいけない
環境からどれぐらい恩恵を受けているのか
環境によってどれぐらい自分が害を受けているのか
両方学ばなくちゃいけない
で 教育を受けなくちゃいけない
人間同士で生きられないんです
教育がなかったら 人間が同じ
人間を追い出すんです
お前迷惑やと言うんです
残酷ですよ だから教育を私は嫌ですとかね
犬猫は何の教育もなく元気でいるでしょうにと
私は自然法則に従って教育は受けませんと言ったら
その人にとってはもう生きることはできなくなるんです
誰が教育するかというと
犬猫じゃないんです 人間です
それだから我々にとっては良い人間関係
と それを支える良い生活も必要です
残念です 人間に生まれたら人間関係を作らなくちゃいかんのです
だから 良い人間関係を作るためには
自分の生き方も関係あるんです
だから自分の生き方は自由じゃなくなっちゃうんです
人間関係が壊れないように
自分自身の生き方をコントロールしなくちゃいかん
制御しなくちゃいかんですね
それでは 親 教師 先輩などが教えるが
そういうの一応教えてくれますよ
こんな若な人々が自分に親切にあんたこうしなさいと
出なきゃ大変やと 親 教師
先輩たちが教えてあげる
それでうまくいくかというと
そうではないんです なぜならば
そういう人々も不完全な人間ですね
そんなうまくいっているわけじゃないんです
教師にしたっても完璧に生きているわけじゃないので
いろいろトラブルがあるんです
親にしたっても完璧に生きているわけじゃないんです
いろんな失敗があったり
トラブルがあったり 間違いを起こしたりしている人なんです
しかし 自分の子供にはできるだけ教えてはあげるんですね
だから その教えですべてうまくいくということはないんです
教師が教えたものですべてうまくいくということはないんです
会社に入ったら先輩がいろいろアドバイスするんだけど
それだけでうまくいくわけじゃないんですね
だから なんか自分で一人でいろんなやらなくちゃいけない宿題も成り立つんですね
そういうことで 常に逆境なんですね
生まれたら それであの仏教のアドバイスありますね
これは全く違うことです
そういうトラブルがあるんだから
常に逆境で生きているんだから
それで黄金時代でったっけ？であっても
その時その人はそんなに感じないんです
その時も逆境なんです
そういうわけで 仏教では他人に迷惑をかけないために
他人の助けになるために道徳倫理を教えます
他の宗教と比較すると
仏教はもうあえてものすごい道徳倫理をものすごく重んじるんです
これ 仏教のベースなんです
ファウンデーションなんです
他の宗教にも道徳あるんだけど
そちらにはそれなりの教理学あるんだから
神 あるいは超自然存在
そちらにつなげるための
神に好かれるための道徳なんです
だから 人間の方を見て作った道徳ではないんです
だからモーセのあれでも
あのイエホワが言わない
私は全知全能だから お前ら私のことを気にする必要ないやと
互い仲良くしなさいと
親を敬いなさいよと 知識ある人を先輩を敬いなさいよと
同じ人間同士で戦うなよ
それ言えばいいでしょうに
それ私に関係ないんだよとは言ってないんです
私の気に入らん だからやめなさいという態度でしょ
だから道徳はどんな宗教でもありますけど
なんか迷惑になる場合もありますね
だからみんな揃って仏教道徳に悪口を言うんです
だからひどいんですよ
非道徳を持ってきて 非道徳だと非道徳を持ってきて
真の道徳には攻撃する
それは人類には幸福になることはありえないんです
そういうことをやると
それで仏教の道徳っていうのは
他人に迷惑をかけないために
他人という場合は地球上のすべての生命を入れるんです
仏教は みんなどんな悪口言ったってもいいんです
仏教の立場は 地球に生きる生命にはみんなに生きる権利がある
だって大地が支えているんだから
野生の動物が森の中でいることで森は元気になるんです
森の葉っぱ食べているかもしれません
で 肉食動物は鹿を取って食べているんです
かわいそうと言ったっても
それによって鹿たちも元気でいるんです
鹿たちだけいると もう自然破壊です
森がなくなって砂漠になるんです
だから鹿を取って食べる動物も必要なんです
だから この よく考えると
地球は優しく守っているんですね
食べ取って食べる生命も
取られて食べられる生命も
両方優しく守っているんです
ですから 生きる権利はすべての生命にある
だから迷惑をかけないという場合は
他の他人って人間だけでもないんですね
まあ最低人間だけ で迷惑をかけない
そのための道徳なんです
それから人に助けられなくてなくては生きられないでしょう
自分が道徳を守っているならば
人を助けてくれるんです
自分が嘘をつかないならば
人を助けるでしょうに
喋ったら嘘だったら誰が助けるんですかね
喋ったら嘘 喋ったら騙された
喋ったら騙された その人は本当にお腹が空いちゃって
私はもう本当にお腹が空いちゃってどうしようもないんでしょうと
食べるもの何もないんだよと
何かくれませんかと お前に騙されませんが
出て行けと言うんですね
また来たと 人を騙して馬鹿にしやがって
ということで追い出すんです
だから道徳を守る場合は
人間はその人を守るんです
ですから この心の働きを知り尽くして語られた仏教なので
教えなので そのまま実行すれば誰でも生きる戦いで勝利を得ます
ブッダの教えは正しくなかったとか
そんなことを置いておいて
ブッダが心の法則は知り尽くしているんです
当然 ブッダは車の組み立て方は知らないと思います
しかし 心の法則は知り尽くしているんです
だから道徳を説かれたんです
だから仏教とは道徳を守る場合はあまりガチャガチャ考えません
ブッダに言われたから
それで終わり 私は人々をけなす場合も
日本でね けなした場合も
私はこういう生き方はブッダに言われたからやってますよと
なんであなたが言う通りにやらなくちゃいけないんですかと
やりますよと しかし あなた今証明してください
あなたはブッダより優れた人間であることを
ブッダより物事を知っていること
ブッダよりあなたの性格は完璧であることを証明してくださいと
それだったらあなた言う通りにしますよと
だからいかに人間っていうのは
そう言った人はそれっきりでも
もう何もできなくなっちゃって
もう黙ったんだけどね
偉そうに人を馬鹿にしやがっちゃって
だから私は 私はどんな場所にいても負けませんね
それはもう別にブッダに言われた通りにやっているからなんです
自分の力じゃないんです
だから道徳にはものすごい人を守る力がありますよ
それでみんな囲まってギャーギャーと私を攻撃するところで
私は一言葉でみんな倒しちゃったんです
それで あ ではもうみんな遅くなったんだから
じゃあ解散しましょうと
それで解散しちゃったんです
そういうことでね だから道徳ぐらい守るならば
環境に勝ちます 逆境に勝ちます
それから道徳っていうのは
信仰 喋ることと体の行為でしょ
性格どうしますかね 性格を直さなくちゃいけない
これって大変ややこしいんです
お釈迦様がもうもうワクチン投げたんで
これを打っちゃえば大丈夫だと
だから性格の悪いところ
全部ブッダが教えたワクチン注射すれば治っていきます
気にする必要はないんです
例えば我々はコロナワクチンを打ってもらえば
体にウイルスが入っても
私は心配する必要はないんです
ワクチンがもう頑張って抗体作って戦う戦うんだからね
そのブッダが性格を直すワクチンとして教えたのは慈悲喜捨なんです
だから自分の性格についてごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ考える必要はないんだ
慈悲喜捨 素直に正直にやってみれば
余計なことを言わないで
だから素直という言葉が大変大事なんです
素直にやってみると 抜群に性格が直ります
ですから 慈悲喜捨の精通になった人に逆境っていうことは成り立たないんです
その人にあるのは生老病死の問題だけです
他ないんです だから八苦と書かれているでしょうね
生老病死と怨憎会 愛別離苦と
あの遭遇不得ってなんとかね
期待するものは得られないっていう
ね なんか不得  不得です
ん？得不得 求めて得られない
グフ グフとグフドッコ
そういうことだから その人にはそういうのも効いてるんです
小籠病性は残ってるんです
だからどうしようもないんです
しかし悩まない 当たり前だから何？っていう感じで意識しないで生きているんです
だからそれでも逆境 逆境に勝っているんです
同時に人が素晴らしい人間に成長しているんです
進化しているんです 生かして生きるやり方は仏教の教えですね
だから俗っぽく言えば生かして生きるということですね
はい はい 基本的にはすべてまとめてみると
問題は心にあるんですね
体にあるわけじゃないんです
生きることは心が行う行為です
生きるということは どんな生命も生きているんですね
それは心がその行為をやっているんです
心の営みなんです 物質には生きて生きいていなくちゃとかね
死に死にたくはないとかないでしょうに
肉体は物体でしょう 物体のは関係ないんです
心あるからなんです だから
で 心が主観的にしか物事と自分のことを考えません
心に問題あるんです 私が生きたいと思うだけであって
まず私は存在しない ただ思考するために
ちょっとこのアルゴリズムが必要で
この概念が コンセプトが必要です
生きたいと言ったっても意味がないでしょうに
ですから 私がというフレーズを入れておくんです
皆さんは瞑想を教えて
私はまあ痛くなったら体がね
痛みと言ってくださいって言うでしょ？痛い痛いと実況してはいけませんと
大体みんな私が間違っていると思いますけど
痛いなの痛いなのに痛いと言ったら何が悪いですかと
完璧に悪いんです あの幻覚のアルゴリズムを使っているんです
痛み ですから 痛みが生じ...痛みは体に肉体に起きませんよ
肉体は物質 物質には痛みがないんです
お医者様がどう説明しても
物質の働きじゃないんです
脳はああやこうや 神経細胞をああやこうやとかね
で 神経壊れたらそこら辺痛み感じないでしょうとかね
そんなデータ出したからといって
物質には痛みがないんです
窒素 酸素 カーボン そういうのは物質で
それで体ができているでしょ
それに痛たがっている窒素
見たことがないんです
痛がっている炭素見たことがないんです
あ この炭素すごく痛がっているとかね
我々お香をたてる時はあれ
炭使うでしょう 炭というんですかね
あの炭なんとかっていうね
痛いと泣いて私も使いますけど
泣いたことはないんです
だから心があるからでしょうに
だから痛いと言いたくなるんです
主語が必要になっちゃうんです
残念ながら主語は存在しないんです
だから痛みと実況する場合は
みんななんとなく違和感感じるんです
それは私のせいじゃなくて
本人の自我のせいです
そういうことで この心は基本的にこの観念的な概念を使って
それを表にして それのそれをこの何て言いますか
優先にして すべて思考を組み立てているんですね
では 人間のすべての思考の最初の行が私がいる
それからすべて成り立つのです
今日は寒いですねということは成り立たないんです
私がいるということがなければ
今日は昨日より寒いです
成り立たないんです まず私がいる
それからなんです コロナって怖いですねと成り立ちません
私がいる 次 やっぱりコロナが怖い
そこで心のベース概念になっているのは私ということだから
心の思考には初めからも問題があるんです
主観なんです それから考えるとき
優先はまず自分のことを優先で
余裕があったら他のことを考える
仕事をしなくちゃいけないという考えあるでしょ
ものすごくお腹が空いてくる
どちら優先？自分優先です
ですから心はこの命っていうのは
心さえもネットワークでないと成り立たないと理解していないんです
例えば私の心に見る力がある
見られませんよ ネットワークないと
目やらいろんなことがないと
見える対象とかね 光やらいろいろ
そのネットワークないと見えたという着眼点が生まれません
それに俺が見ているというのはどういうことかと
それで見えると言っても
科学的に数学的に見えるわけじゃないんです
バラの花があって それを見たら気持ちが生まれる
それだったら A がある
B がある それで結果として C があるでしょうに
それでもう一度 A 出したら目が目がもう変わっているんです
だから B は B スラッシュになっています
B1 か何かになっているんです
前の B じゃないんです
それで結果として生まれる感覚がCでしょ？前のCじゃないんです
ですから 眼識ということも環境依存なんです
目で物をよく見て判断して
そんな成り立たない もうどんな風に見えるかと
環境依存 ですから 自分が生きるっていうことは
環境依存でネットワークで成り立っているんです
生きることは心の作業であって
眼耳鼻舌身がを回転させることであって
それには外にある色声香味触法が必要です
心はこれ理解しないんです
ネットワークだと え？私は心として別々にいるんだぞと
いるわけないでしょう
環境依存で成り立っているだけで
心も こういう状態って無明としか言う単語がないんですもう
だからもう 間違ったのはもうきりがなく
初めから間違って全部線路を間違った方に立っていたんです
どこを進んでも間違った方向を進んでいるんです
無明は貪瞋痴はじめとする無数の感情を作ります
これで自分のことしか見えない殻が出来上がるので
捏造した概念で主観的である感情を優先して考えるのです
判断能力が失います だから結果として逆境に対応できなくなる
人間が逆境に負けているのは
心の心がアホだからなんです
逆境っていうのは自然法則で
それにあることでありがたいでも嫌でもどちらでもないんですね
その中でどう生きるのかっていうことは
こちらの仕事で だから波は怖いだけど
サーファーにとっては波はありがたいんです
なぜ？知ってます 波が来たらどうするのかと
だからサーファーは波を待っているんです
来てちょうだいと 下手な私が
あーやだ 怖いだと逃げるんです
だから波は逆境だと と言うならば
私が負ける サーファーが勝つ
勝ったからといって波を壊したわけじゃないんです
面白い勝ち方なんです
はい 生命はやっぱり人間はね
この心の問題を考えた方がいいと思いますね
心の問題を考えて解決するならば
逆境なんかはないんですね
サーファーの例も覚えておいてください
はい もうちょっと進んで
知恵の立場から問題考えてみましょう
災難は自作自作自縁でしょうかと
今まで言ったこと なんかちょっと違うね
今まで言ったのは 災難は自然法則で常にあることやと
今言っているのは自作自演やと
これはアプローチですね
今 知恵からアプローチするんです
背く心理 生きることは生老病死の流れです
生きるということは老病死です
それを一つ否定する努力は即避けの生き方なんです
あんまりの馬鹿なんて生きていきたいんだ
生老病死でしょうに いや
生老病死は嫌やと 自然の自然の流れに背くことは
自分で逆境を招く行為です
だから逆を逆境を自分で作っている
自作なんです すべての人間が生老病死に向かって戦っているでしょう
だから 去年までなかったものが生まれた
COVID 19 という
まあ戦ってますね それを潰そうと
だから 初っていうのは問題のスタートです
コロナ自体は何のこともないで
本当にもうもう鳥に鳥にも足らないぐらいのウイルスでしょうに
それ現れたところから大きな問題が生まれるんですから
昭和は危険です まあとにかく生きるということは
そうやって生老病死っていうのは流れなの
それに逆らうっていうことは意味がないんだけど
人は逆らっています 若返りする薬飲んだり
運動したり いろいろ 生老病死を乗り越える道は
人が考える生きる道とは正反対方向にあります
生老病死は嫌で苦なんです
ありがたいと思えないものなんです
だから人間が戦うんです
その戦い方ではダメなんです
全く反対に戦い方があるんです
それをブッダが教えているんです
健康に食べ物を食っちゃえば
年取ることはなくなるっていうのは嘘です
世界一いい医者が自分と親しいんだったら
まあ病気には勝てると
嘘です 金があれば病気になったら世界の一番優れた施設に入れますよと
だから大丈夫ですよ 嘘です
何かの治療に世界トップの病院組織があったとしましょう
自分にお金があって ガクンとそれに入られると
だからって病気治る？嘘でしょ？そちらでも人は死にますからね
世界一流のがん研究をやっているところでも
がん患者さんも死にますよ
だから人間やっている道がまるっきり違うんです
それはもう嘘です お釈迦様が反対の道があるんだよと
反対にやってくださいと
生老病死を無視する人は
生に固く執着しています
この連中は生きていきたい
どうしてもと思っているんだから
そこを初めから間違いでしょう
生きていきたいとは生老病死が欲しいということでしょう
いや 生老病死は嫌です
しかし生きていきたいと
何言ってるんですかね
水は大嫌いが泳ぎたいと
成り立たん話でしょうに
そういうわけで 人々にちょっとした病気があるんです
生に執着するという ちょっとしたじゃなくて重症です
生きることに執着する
すべては無常なので 執着は無駄な努力です
執着不可能です 空気を手で握るような感じで
空気は手で握られません
だから生に生きることに執着しても成り立たないんです
苦労するだけ 疲れるだけ
あのネットで水を汲むような感じで
私はこのネットでとにかく水を汲んで
この入れ物をいっぱいにするんだよと
どうぞ頑張ってください
永久的にあの器がいっぱいにならないんです
それが人間の生命の生き方なんです
だから宿題終わってないんだから
ネットで水を運んで あれを器に入れる
また運んで器に入れる
まだどれぐらいやりますかと
だから輪廻という風に言うんです
執着を捨てることが安穏の道です
だから いたって簡単 答えは執着を捨てる
ただそれだけ で すべてにそう言えるんです
生老病死の苦が消えるんです
執着あるから苦なんです
だから自作自演なんです
地震が起きたらすごい困るでしょ？地震は起きてはならぬと思っているバカだからでしょ
逆に考えれば地震は起こる
この辺で起きたら 自分が住んでいる家も潰れる
潰れるでしょうと それで本当に地震が起き
自分の家が潰れてきたという
あ なるほど 自然ですね
そう思ってないでしょ？地震が起こる
別なところで起きてくださいと
地震が起きたら家なんかは潰れる
別な人の家を潰っても
うちの家は安全にしてほしいという
そこで苦しみが生まれるでしょう
津波が来てたくさんの人々が亡くなったんですね
何年か前に ものすごくみんな苦しみに陥ったんですね
その苦しみはなぜ生まれたかというと
自分の希望でしょ 自分の期待でしょ
おじいさんは流されて欲しくなかったとか
おばあさんが寝たきりでしたと
で 流されたと 耐えられない
別に自然の流れですよ
あの期待 希望 それに伴う思考妄想が苦しみを作るんです
だから逆境という概念が自分が作る自作自演なんです
だから執着から生まれるんです
執着捨てればもう全く違うんです
世界は その人に はい 物事
まあちょっとしたまあ新たなアイデアですけど
物事はあなたの希望通りには進まない
希望通りに進まない 立てた計画は実行できない
希望期待があればあるほど
すべて逆境です 希望がなければ
あ 逆境ということにならんでしょ
期待がなければ 我々にはそんな権利ありますかね？自然界に対して
希望を期待することが
サーファーが希望したら波が出てくるわけじゃないんです
だから海で波が現れてくると
それに乗る それだけ そちらに希望が入り込んじゃうと
今日はいろんな技して
技を出して いろんな訓練してやるぞと希望を持って海に行く
行ったら海はおとなしい
今日は まあ落ち込むね
それである日 友達と一緒に海岸で酒飲んでパーティーやろうかなと思って行く
その日で海が荒れ 荒れて
荒れて え？荒れて ものすごい波
悔しいんです なんで今日に限って昨日サーファーやってやろうと来たのにとかね
だから自分の心でしょ
この逆境を作っているのは
それからコロナ攻撃も逆境だと感じるのは
以前の状態に執着と希望があるからです
コロナウイルスっていうのは毎年かかってくる自然の流れなんです
今度こそはもう感染弱いウイルスですけど
感染能力だけ持ってきたんですね
インフルエンザウイルスです
そこでそこで我々はすごく精神的に苦しんでいるのは
元通りになりたいんです
コロナがなかった以前状態になりたいからなんです
だからコロナですから
今どうやって身を守るのかと考えればいいのに
それは結構手抜き だから東京は緊急なんとか
緊急事態宣言  宣伝するまでにも進んだんです
それでも一般人が気にもしない
まだ気楽で気楽ですかね
あれはただの感情でしょ？わがままでしょ
それが あ これって毎年来るもんだからね
じゃあ自分の体と周りを守ってあげなくちゃ
それだけでしょ どうすれば守るの？と専門家に聞いて
それやればそれが自然なんです
マスクけることは不自然じゃない
ああ まあ嫌だ 早くもこのマスクを捨てて捨てたいとね
思う場合は過去に戻りたいってことなんです
もしコロナが消えて我々マスクさせても
これ過去に戻ったことじゃないんです
だから元通りにならない
何一つも それわかってくださいと
何一つ元通りにはならないんです
物事は変化して変化して進むだけ
今はね もう新しいフレーズができているでしょ？ニューノーマルという
だから知識人知ってるんです
元に戻らないんだと コロナもまあ五
六年持つんだよと ワクチンあってもコロナがもう変身しているんです
頭賢いのはコロナの方が人間のほうがよくわかんない
ワクチンが出来上がると
古いコロナの形がもうないんで
もう変身しているんです
だから今わからないのは
新しいバージョンにワクチン効くかどうかわからなくなってるんです
大変でしょう まあとにかく物事を考える人はニフノーマルという言葉を使っているんですね
その場合は まあコロナあることは普通で
それに感染しないで生きることはノーマルで
で ニフノーマルというんですね
要するにノーマルには戻れないんです
これはニフノーマルなんです
何一つ元に戻れないということが事実です
一期一会を物質にも環境にも人にも当てはまるんです
一回だけ はい はい それからちょっと経典勉強して話を終了しましょう
えーまあ これからまあ
財家の生活についてお釈迦様の教えですね
安定した財家生活 これっていうのは
安定したっていうのは固定したじゃないんです
ずっと頑張らなくちゃいかんのです
はい 安定安心 はい ストップではないんです
アンガッテーラワーダのね
ゴータミーはアッタカニッパアッタカアーディニパータじゃなくて
まあアッタカニパータ 6番目のゴータミーワッガというチャプターの 4番目の経典ディーガジャーヌスッタン
このこのディーガジャーヌという人が
私たちは財家でしょうと
だから金銀使ってますよと
贅沢はやってますよと
家族はいるんだよ 友達もいるんだよと
ゴージャスなパーティーもやりますよと
で 財家の生き方言ったんです
そういう我々にこの世で幸福になる
だから財家やめる教えじゃなくて
死後も幸せになる教えがある
お釈迦様は解脱に達しなさいと言っているんだからね
うるさい 我々に何か教えがあるのかと聞いたんです
お釈迦様は別に何のことなくね
8項目で喋ったんです
覚えてくださいと  1 この世で幸福に暮らせる項目は 4つ
一ウッターナサンパダ
これ翻訳日本語訳すると精進しなさいなんですけど
お釈迦様そうではないんで
解説をお釈迦様がするんです
これでウッターナサンパダっていうのは
自分が何かしら仕事をしているでしょ
収入を得るために この仕事のプロになりなさいと
ものすごく仕事を世界
自分の世界をよく理解して
よく勉強して 自分の能力を毎日上げるようにしてくださいと
どうすればもっとうまくいきますか？とかね
だから まあ毎日精進しなくちゃあかんです
仕事は安定した仕事 あれ
日本語のフレーズですかね
安定した仕事っていうのは
私はもう怒らなくちゃ腹が立たなくちゃあかんね
どこにあるんでしょうか
安定した仕事っていうのは
だからみんな失敗するんです
安定しないんです まあ世界中みんなiPhoneとかApple会社の品物使って安定してるんですかね
毎日新しいカラクリを考えて新しいバージョン出さないと
で 向こうもネタ切れで新しい
昨日ビデオ見たんだけど
YouTube でね  iPhone 最新バージョンともっと古いバージョンを見て比較するんですね
その人言うのは専門家です
I don't understand what the differenceって言うんです What's
the difference? この人言うんです
いちいち比較して見せてね
だから結局我々の言葉で言えば
一体何なのかと 一番新しいiPhoneというのは
だから それでそちらネタ切れになっちゃうと安定しないでしょう
それで別な系のね  ANDROID 系の携帯が進む可能性はありますね
そちらの方が知識人の幅が広いんだからね
だって会社がたくさんあるんだから
あれは独占 独占的な もう閉鎖した世界だからね
ですから この職業の場合は日々精進すること
単純な日本語で言ってる仕事を頑張っていますではないんです
仕事の中身 どんな方法でやった方がより良い結果が出るのかと
どういう風にやった方がスピーディーになるのか
どういう風にした方が品数上がるのか
毎日そこを精進しなくちゃいけない
だからウッターナサンパダっていうのは
修行する人々にとっては悟りに達するための精進なんですけど
お釈迦様はあえて俗世間にそれ解説してあげたんです
こうしなさいと 負けるわけないでしょう
仕事のすっごい腕が上がってるプロになっちゃうと
右に出る人はいないっていうところになっちゃうと
それで在家生活は俗俗世間的に安定してるでしょ
しかし その安定は毎日の努力の結果なんです
努力サボった途端 安定も壊れてしまいます
2番目 アーラッカサンパダ
それ守ることなんですけどね
お釈迦様が言うのは あんた苦労して
正しく汗を流して血を絞って得た財産
国が持っていかれる可能性ありますよと
時々ありますよ ちょっとしたこのデータのミスで
あの あんたもう報告は間違ってますよと
だから 1億円払えと財務省が言うんですね
追徴課税  追徴課税 それ払っちゃうと会社倒産してしまいます
だからそうやって違法に自分の財産取れないように
囚われないように気をつけてくださいと
私はその言葉を入れたかったんだけどね
ちょっと避けたんですね
いわゆる税金払わないでごまかすことを盗むですし
盗むことですけど 税金でもそちらで節約することを考えなくちゃあかんです
払っちゃえばいいじゃなくて
正しく払うところだけ払わなくちゃいかんですね
昔は王様の好き勝手だからね
あいつは金持ちだから
あれ持ってこいと言っちゃうと持っていくんだからね
税金システムなかったんだから
奪いシステムだったからね
ですから 王様の機嫌を取ってあげて
王様にもたまたま何かお土産を持ってきて
ご挨拶をして 王様にも何か自分の家に呼んで接待をしてあげてとかね
そうすると本人の金持っていかないね
それから盗まれないように気をつけなさいと
それから水 火など災害で亡くならないように
このなくではないんですね
漢字は違います あの 守ること大変ですよ
例えば日本だったら水と火だけじゃなくて地震もありますからね
たまに火山もありますからね
そこを財産を守る仕事をやっていると安定するんです
だから安定っていうのはストップしたことじゃないんです
ダイナミックモーションなんです
私が使っているストップモーションじゃないんです
財産を守ることは毎日の仕事です
それやってことね  2番目
3番目 カリャーナミッタタ
それでお釈迦様が性格
に入るんです 戦友 サッダーサンパンナ
信がある シーラサンパンナ
戒律 道徳がある人 チャーガサンパンナ
施しを行う人 パンニャーサンパンナ
智慧がある人と付き合いなさいと
戦友と言ったって あの人
私の仲のいい友達じゃダメです
お釈迦様は条件付コンディション言うんです
このコンディションのある人が戦友だと
サッダーシーラチャーガパンニャーというサッダーシーラチャーガパンニャー 4つ
信というのは まあまあ仏教的に言えば仏教的な信ですけど
いわゆるもう無宗教家で乱暴で唯物論者で
ニヒリズム虚無主義だけではない
シーラサンパン すごく道徳を守る人で
チャーガサンパンナ 人をいつでも用事があったら助けてあげる
パンニャーサンパンナ
智慧がある その 4つある人と仲良くしなさい
4番目 サマジーヴィタ
すごく面白いサマジーヴィタ
これ説明もすごく長いんです
私は言葉 日本語の単語が出てこなかったんだから
英語は入れちゃったんだけど
インカムアンドエクスペンス
収入と  支出ですか  支出
そこをしっかりバランスしなさいと
そこで面白く説明してありますよ
収入のことを考えないで
支出だけであれかこれかこれを買おうとかやっちゃうとバランス
ブッダみたいなものすごい悪い言葉で非難しているんです
たんではないやと もし借金だらけになって終わっちゃいます
逆に あ 金がなくなったら困ると
だから使わないことにすると
とんでもない汚いことやと
だから 得た収入はしっかり使いなさいよと
使って幸せに生きなさいよと
しかし 条件があります
決して収入より支出は上げて上がってはならないと
私はよく金がない 金がないと泣いてる連中はと見たことがあるんだけど
お金が足らない 足らないとかね
私は変だなと普通に思うんで言わないんです
失礼だから そういう人々には支出のリストがあるんですね
結構金額が高いんです
収入のいつもそちら半分もないんです
だから金が足らな足らないけど
どうやってやるんで 自分の収入というのは自分の能力でしょうに
だから収入に合わせなくちゃあかんでしょうに
例えば日本の生活すると
アパート 家賃と電気と水道代などなど
どうしても払わなくちゃいけない固定支出はありますね
それでも固定じゃないんです
自分がものすごい高い家賃の家に住む必要はないでしょうに
それは収入と合わせて考えなくちゃいけない
どこに どんなところに住むのかと
六本木ヒルズに住むのか
そこら辺のアパートに住むのかどうかね
自分が好き好きに 10万
家賃のもうマンションに入り入ってしまって
収入は 1万5000円
15万円やと お金が足らないやと
電気代払えないんだと
どうしてしてくれるのと
どうことあればいいんですかね
また個人的な例はたくさん出せますよ
私には 私は人生長いんだから
私は小さい時からもう支出は収入に合わせるんです
友達がやってるからといってやらない
その 4番目の大事なポイントは
このバランスなんですね
バランスよりもお釈迦様がちょっと収入は上の方にして
ちょっと支出はちょっと低い目にして設定して生活しなさいと
これ 最近の人に名前はディガジャーン
さんに教えたんです どうですかね
ものすごい現代的な教えでしょう
遠い昔の人に教えたんですけど
紀元 6世紀の紀元前 6世紀の 6
まあ 5世紀にしましょう
はい それからこのお釈迦様が財産のものすごい立て
収入がしっかりとバランスシート作ってもこれ気をつけなさいとまた 4つの項目を言うんです
だから我々お金を使うのは何か得るためでしょ
使ったお金は何か得なくちゃあかんですね
それだったらこの 4つやめなさいと
まあこの人男だからね
イッティドゥット女遊び
インドでは結構一般常識であった習慣なんです
で 女性はいろいろ遊ぶ
そうやって性業をやることは
お釈迦様はあまり非難してないんです
その女性の職業 それは
しかし 男たちで行くなよ
ドゥッタっていうのは
もうもうやりすぎ たまに一回という意味じゃないんです
もうやめられない状態にドゥッタという言葉を使うんです
やみつき状態  2番目 スラードゥッタ
酒はもうやめられない状態
だからその場合はたまにお祭りで飲んだとかって
そういうことじゃないんです
酒がなければ それはやめない
得るものはないんです
自分が体 健康も能力も壊れるだけ
結果は金払ってバカになる
金払って脳を破壊してもらうことだからね
3番目 悪賭と賭け事 賭け事はすぐ病気になるんですよ
たまに一回だけやってみたということは問題ないんだけどね
やっぱりもうパチンコみたいにどうしてもやりたくてやりたくて
金が入った途端 パチンコ屋に走る
それで倒産した人々は日本にいるんです
パチンコばっかりやっちゃって
家も売ってしまったとか
得るものはないんです
4番目 パパメット パパ左右
パパサンパ ワニ ワンコ
悪友 悪友っていうのは損ばっかりする
悪いことを悪いことをそそのますからね
だから悪友と時間いたら相当損しますよ
もう得るものもない 奥さんにも怒られる
パパサンガにさんパパサンパワンコっていうのは
この悪に赴く性格 だから自分にもそういう性格あったら
気をつけて戦友と付き合うことにしなさいと
この 4つの項目は 金の完璧な無駄遣い
財産のすべてなくなる
そちらにもいろんなエピソード
ストーリー 仏典にはあるんです
賭け事で億万長者が乞食になったエピソードとか
そこでこの人はもう一つ
やっぱりこの世で贅沢に生きていたっても
死んだら天国に行きたいんだと
もうあまり高いデマンドですね
そこは何のことはない
それを教えているんです
それも 4項目 見てください
ものすごく親切で覚えやすくて
4 4 4 で教えているんです
最後に8に まとめて芸で教えて覚えさせるんです
このお釈迦様は 4 4 4 項目にはすべて入っていることは不思議です
何も抜けてないんです
だから完全たる人のアドバイスを聞くことですよ
親は不完全 親戚は不完全
他のアドバイザーたちもみんな不完全
ブッダに聞けば この八つ八つ覚えなさい
それで終わり はい それで死後の幸福を意味し
項目 4つ サッダーサンパダ
そこで曖昧中途半端ではなくて
ブッダがはっきり言うんです
ブッダの悟りを信じ 信頼しなさいと
ブッダが悟ったこと 誰もあまりわからないんですね
それは当然ブッダも知っています
しかし ブッダが完全たる悟りに達したと信じなさい
そうすると ブッダの教えは実行することができるんです
ブッダが言ったことも悪いこと言ってないんだからね
2番目  2番目 シーラサンパダ
道徳ですね そこであの人にわかりやすく五戒守りなさい
そうすると たまに酒飲むっていうこともできなくなっちゃうんです
上の 2番目  3番目 チャーガサンパダ
欲執着を控えて施しをする
だからこの自分の財産
収入に これすごいあのポテンシャル
エネルギーになるんですね
だから この 収入と出費をバランス考えていると言っちゃうと
施しにもいくら入れますか？って
そうするとケチなんです
そうではないんで 自分の出費に決めたところの範囲から施しもするんです
要するに 家で晩ご飯作ったで
日本ではないんだけど
ちょっと外を見たら なんか身寄りのいない人がいる
それでちょっと待ってください
その人止まってもらって
自分食べるために作ったご飯の一部
一人分ぐらいあげる あるいは自分の使用人
誰かね もう突然子供が病気になって倒れたと聞いたら
もうお金がない もう給料ではもう医療代払えない
それで自分のマスターの主人のところに行って
困りましたね 子供が病気になって
もうもう ああそう じゃあまあお医者さんに見せて
あの治療したらお医者さんにこちらに来るように言ってあげて
それが施しなんです で
その人はお医者さんと話し合って治療する
お医者さんに払う分がお医者さんがこちらの家に来て
それもらって帰る それはできるように
やっぱりバランスシートをしっかり作っておくんです
それが人間とはものすごく欠かす欠かす欠かしてはいけないことだそうですね
施しという習慣で もう一つあります
これネットワークだからね
やっぱり自分得だけじゃなくて
あげることも必要でしょうしね
はい  4番目 パンニャーサンパダ
智慧があること で みんなこの人もね
ジィガジャーナも困ってパンニャーと言ったら困りますよと
お釈迦様とね じゃない
お釈迦様 ウデヤッタガーミニパンニャー
物事は現れては消えるということは
じわじわと理解してくださいと
大げさなことを頼んでないんです
ウデヤッタガーミニパンニャー
いかなる現象も現れては消える
現れては消える これでその人にその智慧が現れたら
解脱のすぐそこなんです
一歩先 解脱なんです お釈迦様は死後天国に行く狙いじゃなくて
できればこいつを解脱させてやるぞって考えたでしょうね
どうしてもいい人やとね
わがままでかわいいやと
これでいかなる逆境にも動揺しないで在家生活ができる
はい 以上です もう一つ経典紹介します
あなたはすでに幸せです
で 日本語で思い浮かばなかったんだから Open
your mind. You are already happy.目を覚ませと
あんたはもう初めから幸せでしたよと
うーん それに私の解説を
解説方法もありますけど
経典に合わせます これはアングッテルニカイのアナンスッタ
チャトゥッカニパートですね
たまに観察するべき 4つの幸福があります
朝から晩までヴィパッサナー瞑想みたいにずっとやる必要はないんです
たまたま一番目Happiness of オーナーシップ
アッティス ちょっと次のスライドに進んでみましょうか
はい あと日本語で書いてますからね
元に戻しましょうね これはパーリ語でアッティスと言うんですね
物事はあるという感じですね
2番目 ハピネスオブエンジョイメント
なんかハピネスオブエンジョイメント
なんか成り立たん 単語ですけど
3番目はハピネスオブデクレストネス
あなたに借金がないこと
4番目は 悪いことをしていないハピネスオブブレイムレスネス
はい 次に行きます で 日本語にして説明します
これスライド書いてるところ
この時期時間になってくると
クタクタ疲れているんだから
なんか日本語を忘れてしまって英語になってしまうということもありますけどね
あるという幸せ  1番目
日本訳を入れてないね
私は  1番目はあるという幸せ
で これはこういう風に考えるんですね
人には 例えば食べるものが必要ですね
あなた 食べるものなくて飢えてもう困ったことはあるのかい？と
まあ食べ物も結構 だから欲がなく
考えれば まあそれなりに食べて生きていられますよと
服はそれなりに服はありますよと
で 薬はまあそれ問題ない
病気になったらまあ保険もあるし
まあ大丈夫だと そんなところ
まあ今住んでるアパートあるんだからね
だからあるでしょ それで生きられるでしょ
ついているでしょ なんでそれに妄想入れるんですかね
アパートじゃなくてマンションだったら幸せなのにとかね
不幸でしょうね 収入ない人がね
マンションの妄想すると
だから自分にとっては今生きられるために必要なものは揃ってるんだよと
と考えると そこで喜びが生まれる
ハピネスが生まれるんです
これはあるということを感謝
あるあるということを感謝して満足すること
ハピネス 楽しを感じること
2番目は財産を使って楽しく暮らしていること
ボーガサンパダ いわゆる使用
需要でしたっけ？消費
消費することの楽しみ
だから消費っていうのは自分あるお金で
まあちょっとまあどこかに行きたくなったら
まあいいお金がありますから
お金使って行く それで １泊泊まらなくちゃいけなくなった
大丈夫 大丈夫って ちゃんとホテル代払って
１泊泊まってご飯も食べて楽しく帰る
それでこれ使用なんか消費したでしょ
自分のお金は それが楽しいでしょ
だからまあ正しく自分が自分の財産を消費しているんだと
例えば外車を買ってガレージに入れて
ビニールシートもまた外車売ってるシートをかぶって置いておくと
それってかわいそうですね
せっかく高いお金で外車買ったならば
それを使ってみる なんかドライブに行ってみる
親戚の親のところに行ってみる
親も連れてどこかで温泉にでも連れて行く
それで楽しみが生まれてくるんです
私は私の財産使ってるんだという使用する楽しみ
たまにそれ考えた方がいいんじゃないかなと
3番目 借金がないんだと
あ お金が足らなくてちょっと借りたとかね
借りないでください 仏教ではお金借りること認めるの
たった 1箇所 あのえっと
インベストメント インベストメント
何でしたっけ？ん？投資
投資 しっかりした計画で事業を始めたいんですけど
まあ資金はないんです
そこで銀行から借りても構わない
計画しっかりできてるんだからね
だから投資以外は認めてないんです
だからアホでいろんな計画
事業を組み立てるんじゃないんです
他金借りたらあなたの人生は大失敗なんです
これはええんで 例えばまあ自分がこの財布持って友達と買い物に行ったところで
財布のお金が足りなくなっちゃった
お金がないわけじゃないんです
友達にちょっと 5,000円足らなくなっちゃったんだけど
貸してくれる？いいよと貸してくれると
それで 5,000円返せれますね
そういう万が一 ちょこちょこっと
それは借金じゃないんですね
お金がなくて困って借りたわけじゃないんです
借金してはいけないんです
いけない場合で で  4番目
非難を受けるほどの悪行為はしていない
悪いことをしてないよと
だから私はちょっと柔らかくしたんで
意味をね アナワッジスカっていうことをね
まあ大体まあ仏教の方々はよく覚えてもあちこちボゴスカ
アナワッ アナナスかアナワッジスカ
経典の名前もアナナスってなんです
借金ない だから借金はいかに仏教が危険で見ているのかと
で 人はたまたまちょこちょこと悪いことをするかもしれません
しかし 非難を受けるほどのあいつは金持ちですけど
やり方まずいやと いろんなごまかしやってるんだよという風に
それはないんだと 例えばビルゲイツさんに誰も悪口言わないでしょ
世界一の金持ちですけど
悪いことをしてないんですね
まあそこは私は全然みんなに非難される
言われることはやってないんだと
自分自身でその楽しみを味わってみるんです
だから この 4つの項目をたまたま考えて
幸せに生きてみなさいよと
あんたはもうとっくに幸せやと
この項目を 例えばホームレスがいるとしましょう
日本はちょっと置いておきます
インドだったらホームレスっていうのはまた社会の一つのシステムなんです
その人々の楽しみ この楽しみを得られますよ
インドではだいたいもう何かあげるでしょ
だから食べるものは何かしら手に入る
どこかで横になって寝ることもできる
誰も追い出しません だから日本みたいに駅はロックされてないんだからね
駅に入ってホームでも横断って寝ることはできる
誰も何とも言いません
だから寝るところあってあって
吾輩は楽しいと思えるでしょうね
あの人はあの昨日ある人からあのパン一つを分けてもらったとかね
あ これ楽しかったとか楽しいでしょうに
だからホームレスにしても
吾輩は不幸だとかね 思う必要ないんです
ホームレスで日本でホームレスになったのは
それなりの生き方が生き方に問題あったからでしょうに
あるいは自分のせいではないかも
とにかく自分の環境で起きた出来事でしょうに
だから自分はそれにハマっていったより自分の業でしょうに
まあそれでもまあ大丈夫
まあ毛布もあるし なんとか食べられるしとかね
だからあの昔 あの線路の下で
ガードの下で私は男性のホームレス見たんだけどね
ちゃんともう布団敷いて
もう何枚も毛布をかけて
なんか懐中電灯なんかで電気もつけて
電気はあったんだからね
まあ本も見ながらラジオを聞いてるんですね
だから なんでその人に私は幸せだと思えない？ラジオも聞いてるんだから
そういうことで このもうはちゃめちゃ金持ちにならなくちゃいかんということじゃなくて
お釈迦様が人は本当に生きているんだから
それなりに幸せなんですね
だからまあそれなりに生きたい
生きてますよと言ったら
それなりにはちょっと悪い言葉だけで
それで幸せを感じられる
感じられるはずなんです
たまに考えてみると 精神的に安らぎが生まれます
ハピネスは心の感覚です
だからそれ心が作るんです
ものは作りません 環境変化によって揺らぐ必要はありません
たまにこの世を考えていると
心は揺らがぬ 今のコロナ状態であっても
まあ大丈夫か コロナに感染しないで
まあ結構頑張ってますよと
楽しみ感じられるでしょうに
はい で 終わりと思います
で まとめに行きます 物事は常に変化する
現状維持と取り戻しは成り立たない
両方考えて現状維持成り立たない
取り戻しも成り立たない
世界は因果法則で変化するのであって
個人の希望願望は関係ない
個人がいろいろ勝手に願望
希望作っても これは世界の因果法則です
将来に期待することも
過去について悩むこともやめる
今現在の状況を客観的に理解して適宜に対応する
今の状況に対応すればいいんです
無意味な妄想をやめて
執着が少ない明るい生き方をする
それで人は幸せになります
で これでラストだとは思います
うん はい それで今日の講演はこれで終了いたします
はい ありがとうございます
質問状 え？ 質問受け付けますかね
1個来てますけど  はい
来てる  1個に答えましょう
きねこさんという方 施しをするともらうことが当然になる
困った人もいます 何度でも施ししても求められる場合がある
そういう時はどうすればいい？ 求められてする施しは施しじゃないんですね
それでそれだけです で
施しするのは相手が困っているからでしょうに
なんかもうなんで求めるんですかね
感謝しろよすら言ってはいかんです
それと感謝しろならば
もううるさい もう帰ってよと
感謝すら期待する必要はないんです
我々の義務なんですね
本当は幸せに生きるための
施しは相手に求められるっていうことは
ただの商売ですね うん
はい それで終わりです
答えははい  あともう一人方は来てます
千之葉さんという方 初心者ですが
インターネットで仏教を解説する動画やライブをやってもいいですか？ まあ
それはまあ 自分に自信があればどうぞ
人の自由でしょうにね
私に聞く必要はないんです
言論の自由もありますからね
まあ一応引いて言えるのは
まあ自信があってやってください
自信がないんだったら
自分にとっても曖昧中途半端
疑問だったら まあ他人にそれ言っちゃっても迷惑ですからね
それだけ気をつけてください
はい 以上です  はい では
もう時間も結構経ってますので
皆さんで香の文お願いして終了したいと思います
次のスライドになります
はい 香の文 あらゆる生命に憐れみを持って真理を説かれた本師釈迦牟尼仏陀の聖なる教えに従い
我々がここまで進んだすべての功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって 生きとし生けるもののものをすべてが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得られますように
はい 恒例の文章になります
祈願の文章です ドッカッパッターチャニンドッカ
バヤッパンターチャニンバヤー
ソーカムパンターチャニッソーカー
ホントゥサンベーピパーニノー
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
サードゥサードゥサードゥ
はい どうもありがとうございます
カンティーパラマンタポーティティンカーニッバーナンパラマンワダンティーブッダ
パー